[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar impaired dendritic cell homing
in covid19
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by vizio farm to learn more visit
viziofarm.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation you
can report your problem by using the ask
a question box as well
all questions will be answered by the
speakers via the email address you
provided at the time of registration
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
lucas boercherding medical student
technical university of munich and ralph
huss md ph.d head of the center of
digital medicine and deputy director of
pathology
university hospital in ausburg germany
lucas dr huss you may now begin your
presentation
welcome to the webinar on impaired
dendritic cell homing
in covet 19.
i welcome you from the institute for
pathology and molecular diagnostics
at the university hospital in augsburg
germany
my name is ralphus
i'm a professor of pathology at the
institute of pathology and molecular
diagnostics
and at the same time deputy director and
professor
at the centre and institute of digital
medicine also in augsburg
the institute of pathology
is part
of the large regional and university
hospital in augsburg
serving more than 2 million people
in the region
this of course
also implies
the medical care for those patients who
have been infected
by covet 19
pandemia and associated diseases
one of our main focus
over the past two years
of the kovit 19 pandemic
was
the performance of autopsies to better
understand
the disease
and the consequences
for the progression
of the disease
and potential treatment
opportunities
in this map you see all autopsies
performed
in germany
as you can also see
that augsburg
was the second largest centers
performing such autopsies
only a hamburg
performed more autopsies but most of
them were of forensic
origin
and with a different focus
than
what the institute of pathology has done
here in augsburg
during the first wave including the
variance alpha and beta
knight and autopsies were performed on
22 covet associated death
which resulted in several publications
on such autopsies
here is just a selection
of some of those publications
dealing
with the way autopsies should be
performed
in a highly
contagious
disease
which is
associated with a very high mortality
some studies
also included the mapping
of the viral load throughout the body
and of course with particular focus on
the presence of the virus
and virus strains
in lung
and the upper airways
today my colleague lucas boscherding
after my introduction will present his
data
on
impaired dendritic cell homing in
covid19 lungs
let's try to understand
why this is so important
kovic 19
predominantly affects the lung tissue of
infected patients
and during this infection
it causes a diffuse alveolar damage
in different
stages
and most of the viral rna
was detectable in the upper airways and
lungs
while there are also other
parts of the body
where
while dna could be detected but at a
certainly lower
frequency
and tighter
as mentioned before
there are three clinical
stages of diffuse alveolar damage
associated with covet 19.
the first stage
is the so-called exudative diffuse
alveolar damage
which causes the thickening
of the membranes
and
also a thickening of the alveolar walls
which will decrease the exchange of
oxygen between the airways
and the blood
during the second clinical stage of dad
called organizing dad
a proliferation of fibroblasts
starts to continue the thickening
of the overlap walls
and also stiffening more
the entire architecture
of the lung
the end stage dad
con
continues with increasing solidification
of the lung tissue with more collagenous
fibrosis
and very stiff lung tissue
which
almost completely hampers the exchange
of oxygen
of course the
clinical
surveillance
and critical care of those patients
increasing during the different stages
of the
disease
requiring more intensive care
and also extra membranous oxygenation of
the blood
we also looked
into some
possible
explanations
of the immune response
in the different stages of covet 19 d a
day
and came along a publication by nienholt
at al
who described two distinct
immunopathological profiles
in lung autopsies of kovite 19.
one population
showing high interference levels while
others seem to have lower interference
why is this so important
interferon is a critical player in the
maturation and activation
of certain cellular immune components
it is involved in the maturation and
homing of genetic cells
along with the presentation of
tumor and viral antigens and also the
activation of hope and homing
of antiviral t cells
and also
the selection of antibodies generated by
activated
b cells
only if this entire cellular portfolio
does exist
at a functional level and a significant
number
a viral infection can be
coped with
and a patient has a chance to survive
the disease
along those lines
there have been other
publications
explaining the role
of covit 19
and associated viruses
in the immune response
it was shown that the up regulation and
presentation of viral antigens
could be impaired
due to a
lack of mhc class 1 or 2 upper
regulation
and saskoff
can also be able to infect monocytic
derived dendritic cells
which
interferes
with the functional presentation of
antigens to allow an activation of t
cells
at the same time
zazkov zwai also
changes the expression
of certain chemo kinds
which might
alter the homing
of genetic cells
to the affected organs
simultaneously
there are data pointing towards an
impaired maturation
of dendritic cells
so many questions
remain
even after two years of covet 19
pandemic
it is still a question on the role of
immature dendritic cells
on their maturation and their
possibility
to
reprocess antigens
whether
the recruiting and activation of
immature dendritic cells
is hampered
due to virus infection
whether activation including the
presence of danger signals
is still present
and other mechanisms that involve the
maturation
of genetic cells
and an adequate
cell mediated immune response
one of the aspects
of the
immune response
with particular focus on the role of
dendritic cells in diffuse alveolar
damage will be presented
by my colleague and student at the
institute
lucas barcelona
thanks so much for the introduction
professor hosts
all right let's get to our brief
research report impaired dendritic cell
homing in kovic 19 which was published
in frontiers in medicine pathology in
november 2021
my name is lucas boscheling i'm in the
last year of medical school and the
technical university of munich and i
paused in 2020 for a year to do a bit of
research in augsburg
what we wanted to do was take a look at
the inflammatory infiltrator in the
lungs of fatal covit-19 cases
in this particular study we examined the
lung tissue of the covet 19 autopsies of
the first wave in augsburg
at that time there was a huge amount of
papers on covert 19 getting published
and some of these focused on the immune
dysregulation
however we found that most of these
works were about the peripheral blood
count so there were actually very few
studies taking a look at what one might
call the most commonly affected organ
and covet 19 which is the lung
now there were a few works using
conventional immunohistochemistry and
autopsy tissue and some using
bronchoalveolar lavish fluid but not
really detailed descriptions of the
local inflammatory infiltrate
as mentioned before coronaviridae have
been reported to affect dendritic cells
so we decided to investigate the
population of antigen presenting cells
in the first wave in augsburg nineteen
coveted autopsies were performed out of
twenty two covet nineteen deaths in the
university hospital in total
we are still very grateful to the
relatives of the deceased who agreed to
the autopsies during these trying times
now some cases underwent only partial
autopsies which is why we started with
83 lung lobes
all of these cases were first stained
with conventional immunohistochemistry
on cd4 and cd8
there was a very scarce cd8 reaction by
the way
and the lobes that didn't show an
adequate reaction to the stains were
discarded
we then constructed a tissue microarray
of the remaining 81 lobes 10 cores per
lobe and proceeded with the
immunofluorescent staining some showed
processing artifacts and were also
discarded
out of originally 810 cores 608 were
stained satisfactorily in the end
these remaining lung lobes had already
been analyzed for a different study and
assigned a diffuse alveolar damage stage
so in the end we had 608 cores from 71
lung lobes from 17 patients
unfortunately there was not a large
number of m stage three lobes or um
end stage dad
and also not a large number of non-dad
long loops
the stain we used was the ultimate fixed
view apc kit used to stain antigen
presenting cells
so we had cd24b cells on the fitc
channel cd11c for my life dendritic
cells on 5
mhc class 2 and sine 7 and a cocktail of
cd68 and cd 163 to mark tissue
macrophages on texas red
the way this works is that after
staining each floor of organ scan
sequentially so the end result is one
insanely large image file
containing five layers
the fifth layer being dappy to stain dna
that means that every single cell in
theory can take 16 different states
however of course not all of these
states are biologically possible
stay with me just a little longer we
will get to the pretty pictures in a
minute
if you're dealing with this amount of
multi-dimensional data
there's no way around digital image
analysis
for this project the multiplex
phenotyping module by visio form was the
ideal method
to put it simply the first thing the
software does is scanning for the dabby
signal
this process is based on deep learning
if there's a somewhat round structure
with a certain intensity of dappy it
gets marked as a nucleus
again this is a simplification
next for every single cell the intensity
of each channel is evaluated
you can also adjust the settings for
example if you have a rather strong
background signal in one channel
now the module automatically generates a
list of all detected cell types based on
the surface antigen expression
for example there are cells expressing
cd20 only but also cells expressing cd20
and mhc class 2 as well
additionally visio farm also lets you
generate various graphs such as
phenotype plots interactive disney plots
etc
and while we are at it i would also like
to thank alima texan from vizio farm
again for her excellent support and for
her endless patience
here's an example of the user interface
in visio form
on the top left you can see what it
looks like if all channels are activated
as you can see there are four cells and
one of these is very brightly stained
the top right shows what it looks like
when only the dappy and cd11c channel
are activated
on the bottom left mhc class 2 and dappy
and finally in the bottom right is
visiopharm's interpretation of the cells
three of these cells were assigned the
class negative and marked in gray and
one was assigned
the class mhc2 positive and cd11c
positive and marked in bright orange
now at this point it might still seem
like something that could be done
manually if you're very very very
patient
but if you look at what you're actually
going to work with it becomes a bit
overwhelming very quickly
and this is vizio farm's interpretation
of the image
mhc class 2 only positive cells are
marked in pink they're mostly epithelial
cells in this case
we have negative cells in gray
macrophages marked in red and
drumroll
one dendritic cell marked in orange
right here
now this is a prime example of a cell
that would have certainly escaped my
attention
after the classification visio farm can
also be used to automatically count the
cell populations what we have here is
the fraction of cells in a certain
category divided by the total cell count
as you can see we didn't include
end-stage dad lobes in the analysis due
to the low count of only three samples
the b-cell count and the macrophage
count didn't show any significant
differences
but there was an increased count of
myeloid detritic cells in stage 2
compared to stage 1.
interestingly there was no significant
difference in the mhc class 2 expression
by mdc in the different stages
this is remarkable because of the viral
mapping paper by hirschbuilder there was
an inverse correlation of viral load and
dad stage
so we took a closer look to see if there
was a correlation of the mhc class 2
expression by mdc
and the detection of viral rna in the
samples
and we didn't find one
as mentioned by professor huss before in
the process of dc maturation there's a
shift in the surface antigen expression
now activated dc show an up regulation
of mhc molecules as well as
co-stimulatory molecules like cd80 cd86
and cd83
so these markers can be considered
maturation markers
if dc failed to upregulate these markers
this might be a sign of an effective
maturation process
so we attempted further stains of
maturation markers this time using
conventional amino histochemistry
the problem is that these maturation
markers are not particularly specific
for dc
they're also harder to analyze
here you can see a double stain with
cd83 marked by fast red and cd11c marked
by dab
as someone who more or less learned to
do ai analysis before classical ihc
analysis i was kind of surprised by how
ambiguous these states can be
the arrow is pointing to a relatively
easy to distinguish double positive cell
but not all double positive cells were
as good to see
now once again
here's the comparison to the multiplex
stains where you can just switch off the
display of certain channels if needed
and there's also one more problem with
conventional ihc
for me it meant having to count the
cells manually
so analyzing the conventional stains
means sitting in front of the microscope
or the bright field scans for several
days and basically
click a train yourself
while this process is a very repetitive
task it is also highly subjective and
error prone
in the end the ihc stains in general
confirmed our findings but due to the
varying specificity these results should
be taken with a grain of salt
if you're interested in further details
there's a link to the paper at the end
of the presentation
let's recap
we compared the population of antigen
presenting cells in different stages of
diffuse alveolar damage in copit19 lungs
there were no significant differences in
the count of b cells and macrophages but
an increased count of mdc in later dad
stages
there also was no correlation of viral
load and mhc class 2 expression in mdc
at the same time previous works have
established an inverse correlation of
dad stages and viral load
we also stained the lungs for coaster
military molecules using them as dc
maturation markers
none of which showed a higher expression
in early dad stages
what could this mean
in later dad stages dendritic cells
appear to accumulate
there is no significant upregulation of
mhc class 2 molecules and other
maturation markers in early stages
this could indicate a generally hindered
mdc maturation process
as the shift in surface antigen
expression is what enables mdc to leave
the site of acute inflammation at home
to lymph nodes
this disruption of the maturation
process might ultimately lead to an
inadequate activation of t lymphocytes
there are still a few open questions and
some limitations to the study
the first problem is that the case
number was rather small and also we
couldn't investigate lungs of corona
variants
i also don't feel completely comfortable
making statements about non-dad lungs
and of course non-fatal cases would also
be interesting to observe but taking
like samples tissue samples from ards
patients with a known cause is hardly to
justify
i also want to point out that the actual
cellular mechanism is still unclear so
far it's just a theory
so
as always further research needs to be
conducted
if you want to fully understand our work
i suggest you read the original paper as
a webinar of course sometimes requires a
few cuts regarding the content
to read the full paper please follow the
qr code using the camera of your phone
or just use the doi link
that's it thank you for your attention
and feel free to send any questions to
the email address below
thank you
thank you lucas and dr huss for your
informative presentation for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor vizio farm for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions submitted today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you